joe biden will be 82 years old in 2024
he will not exactly be a spring chicken
but nevertheless he intends to run for
re-election
have you decided whether you are going
to run for re-election in 2024 you
haven't set up a re-election campaign
yet as your predecessor had by this time
my predecessor need to need it to
my predecessor oh god i miss him
um no an answer is yes my plan is to run
for reelection that's my expectation
that's his expectation running at 82
is very impressive but more impressive
is actually that joe biden expects to be
voting at 182 which will be much easier
if democrats get their election
reform package through we will examine
all the many people who should not be in
our politics i'm michael knowles this
michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from victor monteiro
adames who says
if women are better than men at
everything why are some
women identifying themselves as men for
example
ellen elliot page well that's very
simple because they're better than men
at being men
it's actually one of the strong
arguments for whatever nonsense joe
biden was saying the other day
of course it cuts the other way when you
start talking about people like
caitlyn jenner or whoever else but but i
think that there's a strong argument
to be had for them much stronger than
the arguments
that joe biden gave yesterday in his
first
press conference as president we had
been waiting
a long long time for that we finally got
it he didn't
didn't really inspire a whole lot of
confidence which is why
i find it's very good to have real
physical assets one great way to do that
acre gold
acre lets you subscribe to gold bars for
as little as 30 dollars a month
you pay each month and once your gold
stash reaches the price of their gold
bars they discreetly ship acre gold to
your house
just recently acre has introduced a new
100
a month subscription to a five gram gold
bar and
my favorite product they've just come
out with amid our nationwide ammo
shortage
they have a solid gold 24 karat 9
millimeter bullet that you can buy right
now
you can't find anything like these
anywhere they're only making a thousand
of them
i would not recommend shooting them uh
that's not a great investment unless you
are shooting it at a werewolf
so go check that out i i really have
enjoyed investing in precious metals
in my life you can do it too
getakergold.com
michael start investing in physical gold
today make sure you go to this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre that
is getacreal.com
thank you aker gold for supporting the
show joe biden finally holds his press
conference
much much later than any president in
modern history held their
first press conference and in it
he he didn't inspire a lot of confidence
he he obviously said
that he has to run for in 2024 because
if he says that he's not going to run in
2024 he
instantly becomes a lame duck so within
two months of being in office
he will be completely ineffective he
won't be able to get
any of his agenda through however when
reporters pressed him on this question
of really 82 years old you're going to
run for president
joe biden seemed to add a little caveat
here
so is that a yes that you are running
for re-election look
i'm i i don't know where you guys come
from man i've never been able to travel
i'm a great respecter of fate i've never
been able to plan four and a half three
and a half years ahead for certain
and if you do if you do run will vice
president harris be on your ticket
i would fully expect that to be the case
she's doing a great job she's a great
partner
she's a great partner and do you believe
you'll be running against former
president trump
oh come on i don't even think about i
don't i have no idea
i have no idea if it'll be a republican
party do you
i know you don't have to answer my
question but i mean you know do you i
mean look this is
the way i view things i become a great
respecter of fate in my life
i set a goal of this that's in front of
me to get things done
for the people i care most about which
are hard-working decent american people
getting really having it stuck to them
so
mr president are you going to run again
i'm a great respecter of fate
does not does not exactly inspire
confidence
since i'm a great respecter of fate oh
my gosh i see the point
that he thinks he's making is that look
anything can happen in this world
and you can count on some people and
then you're going to lose them and
you know i get it he's he's actually i
think referring to
the personal tragedies in his life
deaths of family members
but when you're asked the question hey
you're going to be a little up there in
age are you going to be able to run and
he says i'm a great respecter of fate
i sort of undercuts his previous answer
joe biden he actually got in trouble
yesterday because he was giving an
answer and he said
you know look when i first got to the
senate 120 years ago
and and people are playing this as
though this was some sort of a gaffe i
don't think it's a gaffe i think he was
actually trying to make a joke
but the reality is maybe it wasn't 120
years ago but he did get to the senate a
long time ago
and so that sort of self-awareness even
if he's being a little self-effacing
about it
does remind you this is a a very old guy
by the standards of presidents
and so sure he can he can say you bet
i'm absolutely gonna i'm gonna run for
seven more terms
because he wants to protect his agenda
but i just don't think people
are really buying it now what is that
radical agenda
part of it is ending the filibuster to
be able to ram
through more more legislation than
otherwise he would because i think he
believes that
time may be limited i'm going to say
something outrageous
i have never been particularly poor at
calculating how to get things done
in the united states senate so the best
way to get something done
if you if it holds near and dear to you
that you uh
um like to be able to
anyway
we're we're going to get a lot done and
if we have to if there's complete
lockdown and chaos as a consequence of
the filibuster then
we'll have to go beyond what i'm talking
about
okay um hang on
uh sorry
oh sing me miss kim
oh man i'm
there there are some things when
politicians
flail around and make mistakes and seem
incoherent there are some times
when you can just make a lot of jokes
about it you know there's sometimes when
it's
so pathetic that i actually think it's
sort of wrong to make jokes about it so
i'm not going to
i'm actually going to try to interpret
what joe biden
is failing to say here what he's trying
desperately but failing to say
which is he says you know i've never
been i'm one not one who can't get
things
done in the senate i know and so what
i'm saying is and you can't well
anyway and then he second guesses
himself and he either forgets what he's
saying or
i think even more likely doesn't want to
admit what he's saying because he's he
would be kind of giving away the game
here
but what it what he seems to be implying
is
i don't want to get rid of the
filibuster but
i know that i have to threaten to get
rid of the filibuster to convince
certain senators to go along
with my extremely radical legislation
that i have to pass right now
one because i'm a politician that
doesn't have any beliefs so i go where
the party is and the parties far left
but two because i'm very unlikely to run
a successful campaign
in in a few years so i've got to get it
all done now that's
that is actually what i think is going
on in his head
because not that long ago joe biden was
saying that
he he was praying praying to god that
that we wouldn't end the filibuster in
the u.s senate
is what really is going on here the
majority doesn't want to hear what
others have to say
even it's the truth senator moynihan my
good friend who i served with for years
said
you're entitled your own opinion but not
your own facts
the nuclear open option abandons
america's sense of fair play
it's the one thing this country stands
for not building the player in field
inside on the side of those
who control and own the field
i say to my friends the republican side
you may own the field right now
but you won't own it forever
and i pray god when the democrats take
back control we don't
make the kind of naked power grab you
are doing
so i pray to god that we democrats when
we take back the field we don't have the
naked power grab
that you're trying to do by ending the
filibuster the naked power grab
by ending the filibuster that is the
essence of our country it's what america
stands for right
you cannot speak in more glowing terms
about the filibuster
and you cannot more clearly state you
oppose getting rid of it and i suspect
biden actually does
oppose getting rid of it but he's
obviously quite weak
you just have to listen to those two
clips it's not that biden used to be
winston churchill or anything but he has
obviously declined
he's not really in control it would seem
of much of anything and
he recognizes that he doesn't have a
whole lot of time to get his his agenda
through
joe the prayer is in your power you can
muster that prayer
and and you can actually effect the
change you want
or the consistency you want and not end
the filibuster what what the democrats
are really
worried about here is not that they're
not going to be able to cram through gun
control
you know they'll try to cram through gun
control maybe they will maybe they won't
the bigger power grab is not stealing
our guns the bigger power grab is hr1
and
s1 the corrupt politicians act which is
a
huge power grub to upend our election
system and all the irregularities all
the shenanigans that you saw in 2020
basically to codify them in law and
actually go even further than that
so some people are fighting back against
it including
the governor of georgia where there were
a lot of election questions in 2020
brian kemp has now signed the
republican-backed
election integrity act of 2021.
this is a way to tighten up election
rules to reduce fraud
to to ramp up voter id
to restrict these drop boxes that are
vulnerable to fraud
to expand in-person voting and curtail
the the mail-in votes which are
obviously right for fraud
and a lot of other overhauls as well
some
crazy democrat lady who's an elected
representative down there
was just arrested by georgia state
patrol
after she tried to bust into the
governor's office
and and oppose this the democratic
process and oppose the governor
signing this legislation take a listen
why are you all arresting her
why are you arresting her who
what a performance we're seeing here why
are you arrested because try to bust
into the governor's office
she doesn't have a right to do that what
does she do because she's trying to
interfere in the democratic process
that's why what does she do
the reason i point this out is
be not because i think that republicans
have a right to bust into
people's offices and and but but because
of the obvious double standard where is
the outrage for governor kemp's safety
where's the outrage over someone
interfering with the democratic process
no there isn't any
there of course there isn't any there's
never any any outrage about that because
the
the democrats define the democratic
process as whatever they want
so so expanding the right to vote
defending our democracy
according to democrats is when you get
rid of all the election integrity
measures
and when you try to beef up those
election integrity measures and protect
the ballot box
that's undermining democracy when a
bunch of republicans storm into a
government building
that's an insurrection when democrats
storm into a government building
that's democracy in action and how dare
the police remember when the democrats
were defending the police
on january 7th i guess that was probably
the last time they defended the police
now it's why are you arresting her it's
all such a ridiculous performance and i
just don't think
that the the right should give this sort
of thing any credence
but politics is ramping up people are on
edge it's
hard sometimes for people to sleep easy
at night if you want to sleep easy
though i have a great way to do it
my pillow a lot of people love my pillow
because they think oh it's a good
conservative company yeah that's great
that's cool i'm gonna confess something
to you right now
i would shop at my pillow even if they
were a communist company i would
i would okay because they make the best
pillows and that's just the way it is
and my wife and i fight over them and
that's fine too i don't i don't even
care that this has brought strife to my
marriage i guess i could just buy
another pillow couldn't i
you to check them out they don't go flat
you can wash and dry them as many times
as you want they maintain their shape if
you
do not have a my pillow if you know
someone who doesn't now is the time to
get one
because for a limited time my pillow is
offering their premium my pillows
for the lowest price ever you can get a
queen size premium my pillow regularly
69.98
for only 29.98 that's 40 in savings
kings are five dollars more they're
going to extend their 60-day money-back
guarantee but who cares you're not going
to you're not going to use it go to
mypillow.com click on the radio
listeners square
there you will find not only this
amazing offer but also deep discounts
on all my pillow products including the
giza dream bed sheets the my pillow
mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets i cannot
recommend these products highly enough
call 800-651-1148 use promo code
dailywire and think of me every time you
put your head on your pillow
glad to see that governor kemp in
georgia
is taking election integrity seriously
now
i wish he had taken election integrity
seriously
earlier it sure would be better he would
have faced a lot less criticism from
conservatives
but he should get credit for taking it
seriously now this is a very important
bill i hope that there are similar laws
passed throughout the country
and i hope that republicans fight tooth
and nail to prevent
hr1 and sb1 the corrupt politicians act
from becoming law because this is such a
fundamental transformation
of our elections that it would it would
put republicans not just at a permanent
disadvantage
it would it would upend our our
constitutional order
so cnn very upset about this john kasich
you know that republican john kasich he
showed up on don lemon's show on cnn
to express his absolute fury
over measures like the one in georgia to
protect
our elections that isn't right have them
show some form of identification but
doesn't have to be a picture
that apparently is in that along with uh
limiting voting on sunday which
is also i don't like either that either
let people vote
so then what is going on here i mean as
a
you're still a republican right you you
have a there are some people who come
over
yeah a very good one i'm a republican of
course i'm a very good republican
that's my job i'm the sort of republican
who goes on cnn to bash republicans
oh hey john who did you vote for last
time oh he voted for let me check uh he
voted for joe biden oh okay
you're not a republican then it's just
you're not
you you are a democrat you pretend to be
a republican
so that you can go on democrat networks
and give fake opposition
and pretend that there is some dialogue
happening when there's not
you're all on the same team you're all
supporting the same agenda you're all
supporting the same politicians and
opposing the same politicians
john kasich not the only one not the
only court jester conservative
who pretends to to be a republican but
in actuality exists only
to legitimize the existing democrat
regime michael steele
former chairman of the republican
national committee
he doesn't do this for the cnn he does
this for msnbc and he said that this
election integrity measure in georgia
this
is totally going to alienate black
voters the question
to republicans in georgia and arizona
and elsewhere
that are are taking rights
voting rights away from black people
across this country in places like
philadelphia atlanta
uh uh detroit um how do you think this
ends how do you think this ends for you
do you think you think black folks are
just gonna sit by
and just let you get away with this do
you think the bishop
and others are just going to say oh well
i guess there's nothing we can do the
georgia legislature just passed this and
the governor signed it
every last one of your names go on a
ballot enjoy your time in office
because you're going to see the power of
the vote come back on you like a
hammer like a hammer
for the action you've taken and the bill
that was signed into law today
it is antithetical to everything our
party has stood for
in its history and is antithetical to
everything this country
has stood for is that so
michael steele good republican on msnbc
he's just look he's expressing outrage
here
not outrage of the democrats or by the
republicans i think we can all agree
that what this republican governor did
is terrible even republicans like
michael still hey michael steele who'd
you vote for last time
oh you voted for joe bide oh okay all
right so you're not
you're not a republican you're a
democrat
who worse than the other democrats on
this network
pretends to be a republican you are a
court jester conservative you are
a fake opposition that exists to
legitimize the ruling regime
and worse yet michael steele is
performing his role
by trying to arouse racial tension say
the black voters they're never going to
forgive the gop
for passing voter id laws is that so
is that because i just saw a poll that
came out from hep hep action survey
not just a few days ago that said that
the majority of americans
including a majority of black and
hispanic voters
overwhelmingly support voter id we
mentioned this on the show a few days
ago
77 of americans support voter id
only 15 of americans oppose voter id
92 percent of republicans support voter
id
64 percent of black voters support voter
id so this this idea
that black republicans are going to
turn on on brian kemp for this turn on
republicans
is that's preposterous but it's also
preposterous to say that
black voters in general who skew
overwhelmingly democrat
that black voters in general are going
to turn on people because of voter id
black voters support voter id
the only people who oppose voter id are
illegal voters who democrats use
to puff up ballot boxes that's no crazy
conspiracy theory democrats have been
doing that for a very long time
you can read robert carro's biography of
lyndon johnson
where he describes in excruciating
detail
how lyndon johnson stole the 1948 senate
election
lots lots of nonsense but it's it's a
way to
pretend you know to speak from authority
well as the authority on republicans as
the authority on black voters is that no
you're not an authority on anything
you're
a democrat commentator now who pretends
to be a republican on msnbc or john
kasich as a democrat commentator
who pretends to be a republican on cnn
but in terms of what actual republicans
think and more broadly what actual
voters think
quite different those guys that fake
opposition those court jester
conservatives
are not the future of the gop they don't
know anything about the future of the
gop
they are the failed past of the gop
john kasich does not speak for
republicans i think the 2016 primaries
should show us that and the fact that he
switched sides
that that old thing that we've been
talking about you know before trump
the failed gop of john mccain 08
mitt romney 2012 losing with dignity
what dignity i don't think that's
dignified at all
that's at the minute that they have a
candidate who actually could win
for the first time in a couple few
cycles
what do they do they turn on him they
vote against him
speaking of polls showing some good news
for republicans among minorities
a new poll that was released this week
shows that latino voters
in california these voters that gavin
newsom's counting on he keeps also
trying to inflame racial tensions
and say that his the recall against him
is just because
white people are upset about the
browning of california and that's why
hispanics you know they hate you
hispanics you got to vote for me gavin
newsom
well new poll shows latino voters
they're not
they're not less likely than other
voters to vote for newsome's recall
they're actually more likely than other
racial groups
the probolsky research center
is a nonpartisan latina and woman-owned
firm
so it checks all the the pc boxes
uh they have no client in the recall
election and they find
that latinos more than other racial
groups are leaning toward recalling him
all of this to say i think that when
liberal squishy fake
republicans like kasich or steele or any
of these other people
say that you know the way for
republicans to woo
minorities is to
basically become democrats i think
that's ridiculous
and when identitarian types
say that there's no way whatsoever for
republicans ever to woo minorities
i think that's ridiculous too
if you just if you look at the way the
votes go it's very tricky
it might it might not work out in the
end but
certainly you can grow your
base of support as a conservative among
minority groups
donald trump did that he didn't do
enough to
push him over the edge in the election
though actually the only group he really
lost support among
in 2020 was white men so if he could
have solved that problem he
would have looked pretty good i don't
think
that the way for republicans to do
better among
black voters especially but also they
don't they don't do particularly well
among hispanic voters i don't think the
way to do better
is through pandering i don't think
racial pandering is going to do it
i don't think extolling the virtues of
tax cuts and tax cuts alone
is going to do it i don't think that
abstract philosophizing
is going to do it purely abstract
notions i think
practical politics are going to do it
i think i think getting down into the
nitty-gritty
of look at what this guy is doing to
this state
look at what crazy nonsense these people
are teaching our children
there was there was a a democrat
representative who went on tucker
carlson show the other day
who said one thing that the white
progressives in my party don't
understand is
black democrats are much more
conservative
on a lot of issues than the white
progressives who lead the party i think
republicans have have a way in there
but the way that a lot of republicans
think they're going to win minority
voters is by becoming more liberal i
don't think that's the case
i think the way they're going to come in
is by speaking more plainly about
practical things
about cultural issues that matter that
is a way to do it that's what donald
trump
did and he actually did make inroads
among
those racial groups if only the fake
court jester conservatives on cnn
and msnbc took note they probably don't
care to take note because i don't think
they want the republicans to do much
better
these these racial narratives are simply
ridiculous
andy no my friend you know my friend
andy know
that white supremacist according to the
left-wing media
is a kind of a curious white supremacist
since he's not a white guy but they call
him that is
far right i don't even i don't even know
if he's really that right wing he just
opposes antifa he opposes political
violence he's one of the few
journalists in the country who will go
out there and actually chronicle what
antifa is doing he's got a great book
about this now
he points out that a lot of the racial
narratives are being told are just
ridiculous
that he he tweeted the other day he said
i'm hearing it repeated as gospel truth
that nearly all
american mass shooters are white here
are the photos of mass shooters from
2019 defined as four or more shot in a
single incident
it shows quite a diverse set of faces
and you see when you're looking in there
you see white people you see a lot of
black people
you see what looks like some maybe
hispanic people
some other races in there as well
andy noe is now being accused of
defending white supremacy
for stating what for stating a fact for
just portraying
the depicting the number of the the
types of people the races of people the
background of people who have committed
these shootings
yes that's what we're being told we're
being told that
racial bigotry is not just when you
antagonize someone for their skin
or you hate someone because or you're
making things up
even when you just state facts
even if you just name people who commit
these crimes if you contradict the
dishonest left-wing narrative that is
somehow
bigoted and wrong
mina harris who is a niece of kamala
harris
she she tweeted out after the
horrible shooting in colorado she
tweeted out
about how this this involved white
supremacy and was so terrible then it
turned out the shooter
was not a white supremacist he was a
syrian immigrant actually
was not a christian nationalist he was a
member of a different religion
and so she she deleted the tweet but she
didn't really apologize she tweeted she
said
i deleted a previous tweet about the
suspect in the boulder shooting
i made an assumption based on his being
taken into custody alive
and the fact that the majority of mass
shootings in the u.s are carried out by
white men
so pause right there the majority of
people in the united states are white so
it would follow that crime would be
committed by
the proportion of the population but it
turns out when you look at the
number of mass shootings in the united
states
white shooters are underrepresented
given
the percentage of people in the united
states that are white
i don't think that mass shootings are
are a primarily a product of race
but mina harris does and it turns out
mina harris is completely wrong on
on all of those counts she says yeah
okay i deleted that tweet
because i i just made something up and
was
prejudiced against a racial and sexual
group
i was bigoted against them but my
bigotry
is justified that's what she's saying
saying my bigotry is justified
and you people who want to wait for the
truth to come out
you're you're just what are you you're
defending white supremacy or something
like that
speaking of bigotry against a group of
people is there any more
persecuted group in this country than
christian bakers
this poor guy you know jack phillips he
is the the guy who runs masterpiece cake
shop
we've had him on this show before years
ago jack phillips
he's a christian guy he's a baker and
political radicals keep targeting him
so for a while these these activists
trying to redefine marriage
they go into his bake shop they say we
want you to
create a custom cake for our gay wedding
and jack phillips said well you know i
according to my religious lights the
phrase gay wedding
is isn't is nonsensical uh because
marriage
involves the sexual difference and
moreover my religion tells me i can't
participate
in that ceremony so
sorry you can buy any of our cakes but i
can't
i can't contribute my art toward
this the ceremony that i i view with
moral of program
so he gets sued goes all the way up to
the court he's been litigated all this
there are plenty of bakeries around jack
phillips there are plenty of other bake
shops that they could go to
that would participate in the ceremony
jack phillips doesn't want to but it's
not enough
it's not enough to say live and let live
okay i do what i want to do you do what
you want to do
that's just not how politics works and
the left understands this and the right
i think doesn't really understand this
doesn't understand this jack phillips
must be made to violate his moral
conscience
if this radical political regime is to
survive and flourish
jack phillips must be brought down he
must be made to obey
the politically correct dictates of the
day so now they're suing him again
some lawyer calls him up and says hey i
want you to bake a cake
that celebrates a gender transition
jack phillips says i can't do that i
think that's wrong
violates my conscience i don't i also
don't think it's possible
so i'm not i can't do that you can buy
any of our cakes but i can't participate
and create a custom work for you
so he's getting sued again all in the
name of
of tolerance all in the name of
liberation the people who are doing this
who are persecuting jack phillips
for his religious views and not even
just his religious views before
defending the traditional american way
of life
for defending a view of sex and nature
and marriage
that has been held by everyone
everywhere at all times in history
except for like five minutes ago right
here in the west
the people doing that really think
they're the good guys
they really think that by ruining this
baker's
life they are the good guys
it's like that old sketch you know they
don't realize they're the baddies
they're just nice guys joe biden thinks
he's a nice guy by creating this
horrible problem on the southern border
joe biden was asked in that disastrous
press conference
what about the southern border the
president of mexico is saying you're to
blame for this come on
isn't this your isn't this your fault he
says no way i'm a nice guy
well look i guess i should be flattered
people are coming because i'm the nice
guy that's the reason why it's happening
that i'm a decent man or whatever's
phrased that you know that's why they're
coming because no biden's a good guy
truth of the matter is nothing has
changed
as many people came 28 increase in
children to the border
in my administration 31
in the last year of in 2019 before the
pandemic
in the trump administration it happens
every single solitary year
there is a significant increase in the
number of people coming to the border
in the winter months of january february
march
that happens every year in addition to
that
there is a and nobody and by the way
does anybody suggest that there was a 31
increase under trump because he was a
nice guy and he was doing
good things at the border that's not the
reason they're coming
so that this stuff just isn't true sure
the numbers can go up and down and up
and down but the idea that the
the number of people crossing the border
illegally
has not spiked because of joe biden
after joe biden was inaugurated that's
just ridiculous
the mexico president says that's
ridiculous even jake tapper on cnn is
willing to admit
that's ridiculous they're not getting
across the border a vast majority of
families are being sent back
is that true daniel jake that was not
true in february
which is of course the last month for
which we have a full month's data
according to official statistics
it was 41 of migrants so not a majority
who came in february as part of family
units who were swiftly sent back so many
so many other problems with what joe
biden's saying
but most he says look because i'm a
decent man because i'm a nice man
that i'm flouting our laws
that were passed in our constitutional
democratic republic
that i'm creating awful conditions far
worse for the children
detained than under trump
that i'm incentivizing this horrible
thing and empowering coyotes no it
doesn't make you a nice guy doesn't make
you a decent guy the road to hell is
paved with good intentions
and i don't think biden even has those
it's a naked power grab
and biden biden isn't selling it even
well enough to convince cnn come on man
come on man ben we'll be talking about
biden's press conference
today and and he will be surmising that
perhaps
this is evidence that joe biden is in
slight decline you might say
uh so check check out ben's take also
you can get very excited
tonight is the premiere of episode two
of canvas
daily wires new talk show hosted by
candace owens the show will live stream
over at dailywire.com at 9 pm eastern 8
pm central
featuring special guests john rich
bryson gray
brandon tatum and me that's right you
can get me on there it's going to be a
lot of fun
tune in at 9 pm eastern a pm central to
catch an all-new episode of candace's
new show
are you not a member yet are you crazy
go to dailywire.com
subscribe get 25 off a new membership
with code candace that's dailywire.com
subscribe 25 off with code candace
and if you missed tonight's episode
there's always the podcast version
that's going to drop
saturday mornings a podcast is great
jump to the top of the charts at number
two
but if you want to watch the whole
episode you got to go to dailywire.com
we'll be right back with the mailbag
welcome back to the mailbag first
question from jake
dear michael i'm personally not a
religious person
and i am personally an atheist in your
podcasts you mentioned that the leftist
side of the political establishment
wants to get
to the children through educational
facilities the reason for this is
because younger children are easily
impressionable and therefore it's a form
of indoctrination
so my question is couldn't that be said
of normal religious practice
most children follow the religious
beliefs of their parents essentially
if it was a flip of the coin someone
who's christian could easily be of
muslim or seek faith
if they were simply born into a
different household that held those
religious views which shows that faith
is more dependent on luck of the
household
you were born in than any other factor
in most cases what
what do you believe is the difference
thanks love the show
first of all you're right that people
try to get to children
if they want to educate them but that's
not a bad thing in and of itself that's
just what education is
you children will be educated they you
have to i mean that's just
part of growing up and you will either
be educated
in the right way or the wrong way you
you will children absorb everything
around them they will be taught things
they will learn things that's just what
children do
and so the question is do you teach them
true things and good things and
beautiful things or you do you teach
them false things
and and ugly things that what the left
is doing is going in and
perverting education but i don't think
it's wrong of them to go in and
indoctrinate children i don't think
that's a wrong idea
indoctrination and education mean the
exact same thing they both come from the
very same verb
all education is coercive and you you
don't get to freely choose your
education either
because part of education is learning
how to master your will and develop your
higher faculties of reason
so you can't you can't really do that
when you're
three years old or five years old and
you start kindergarten
the the question of religious faith is
just a matter of how you were born yeah
maybe that's true for some people it's
not not true for me i was an atheist for
10 years
many of my friends are converts or
riverts
most people i know who are who are
really to take their religious and
spiritual life seriously maybe the
majority of them certainly a huge
proportion of them
do not hold the religious views that
they held when they were kids also part
of education though the more you are
educated the more you will be in command
of your higher faculties
and your will i remember when i was 13
years old and
very prideful though not particularly
educated
i i was really taken in by the new
atheists those guys richard dawkins and
christopher hitchens and all that
and read their books some of them and
and it was really convinced and then i
just realized that
the arguments against god are weak they
don't they don't
there really aren't any and the
arguments for god are really
strong and the the thought of someone
like saint thomas aquinas
is a little bit more persuasive than the
thought of
i don't know sam harris or somebody
so that that is part of education but
you're not going to
you don't just begin from the
perspective of okay i'm a fully formed
person
i totally know everything now i can
begin my education no your education is
what
brings you to that point so i don't
think there's anything wrong about it i
think
rather than saying we need to get the
left out of the schools
we need to say no no we need to get the
left out of the schools and we need to
go into the schools and we need to
write the curricula it's not enough to
make formal procedural arguments we have
to actually have something to say
we have to say believe this don't
believe that
and some some conservatives are not
willing to accept that
eternal fact from paul michael i'm an 18
year old
and i have come to doubt the mormon
faith in which i was raised
i would like to explore other christian
churches to see if i at least believe in
christ
this has become a major point of tension
with my parents and i don't know
how to get them to respect my religious
freedom and beliefs what advice do you
have for me
thanks for all you do i love the show
this is very difficult can't blame your
parents
necessarily if they're not immediately
accepting
that that you have a different view of
the world than they do but a christ
comes not to bring peace but a sword
and if you do not hate your father and
mother
you you cannot follow him now what does
that mean does that mean you need to be
mean to your parents at dinner no that's
not what he's saying but
you need to recognize that you you owe
loyalty and duty
and love to your family and to your
community
and to your country but ultimately your
ultimate
uh duty and the ultimate love
is for god
god is love itself right so that that is
your higher obligation
and and you you have to pursue that
light
your your soul will depend on it
and uh and that that is the the higher
obligation
we all have to love our neighbor as
ourselves but first we have to to
love the lord our god with all our heart
and all our soul
so i i wish you luck i will uh i can
pray for you
from brent hey michael i know your prior
thoughts on the criminalization of flag
burning oh yeah i think i think it would
be perfectly fine to criminalize flag
burning it's for those who haven't
i haven't heard this thought before but
i heard a good argument that changed my
mind on this and was wondering if you
would feel the same
basic argument is that some places can't
verbally say anything bad about their
leaders without punishment so if you are
able to burn the flag in the usa without
punishment
just shows how great this country is
compared to all the others i'm
interested in hearing
your thoughts thank you for the show i
enjoy it even though all the other
personalities at the daily wire tell me
i shouldn't
yeah there's a difference here i'm not
saying you shouldn't be able to
burn a picture of joe biden or burn a
picture of donald trump
or burn the symbol of some politician or
other politician
what i'm saying is that there is a
categorical difference between a
representation of politicians and a
representation of the country itself
and to burn the american flag to invoke
the first amendment
as a justification for burning the
symbol of the country
which without which the first amendment
would not exist
is an incoherent action and no country
can survive
if it hates itself it is it is
uh an act that that makes
no sense that will destroy a country if
you have people
who disdain their very country and who
destroy symbols of it so i just think
it's totally different which is why
there were laws against burning flags
for
for most of our country's history until
very recently
and it's it's why so many conservatives
on the supreme court
uh disagreed with the with the idea that
you should be able to burn the flag
or that you could burn the flag as a
matter of constitutional principle
scalia
notably thought that the first amendment
protects flag burning
though this was not totally in keeping
with conservative
legal tradition and i'm not not totally
sure he got this one right but
even if he did get it right i just think
you could you could pass an amendment
saying okay but
you're not going to burn the flag and i
think that would matter and i think that
conservatives who say oh forget about it
it's just a symbol
forgetting about symbols forgetting
about cultural matters
is how we've lost the entire country
through political correctness a process
that i detail by the way in my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds
so i think that the days of the egghead
conservatives who all they care about is
you know tweaking a few aspects of
administrative policy and lowering taxes
i think their days are over i just think
they lost the whole country
and now we need to get much more serious
about culture and about
symbols and the way the way we think
about the country itself from mason
mr knowles oh speaker of truths
i recently finished my first novel and
was planning on publishing it through
amazon
though it is a work of fiction now i am
not so sure
that it is the route to go since it
speaks to conservative topics
such as being made in god's image and
the dangers of china's policy of
technological theft
obviously amazon's actions in recent
months
make me hesitate to use them even though
they remain the best means to distribute
my work to the masses
any thoughts you have on the subject are
appreciated well i think unless you are
an extremely prominent established
writer already
your your odds of being cancelled by
amazon are relatively low so if they're
going to offer you an opportunity to get
your work out there
i don't see any reason not to do it
moreover at least for now
conservatives or rather amazon is not
canceling and banning books
on all manner of conservative topics
just a very narrow
matter of them there amazon is banning
the transgender debate uh ryan
anderson's book when harry became sally
that one's being banned because
it's such a hot issue the left has
absolutely no argument on it
it's really that kind of an argument
especially given in such a scholarly way
as ryan anderson's book
that is a real threat to the ruling
regime and this this dominant ideology
so they're going to kick that out
the they flex their muscles on on lots
of issues but
you know they're not they're not doing
it for everyone for every conservative
issue
at all times so i wouldn't worry about
that too much
i would try to get your work out there
your art out there and then
worry about getting cancelled when that
comes from virinder
dear mr knowles i was wondering about
you as a religious person
what are your views on the non-abrahamic
eastern religions
such as buddhism hinduism and sikhism
also i heard you like indian food what
would you normally order
at an indian restaurant uh came from ben
stayed from michael subscribe for
candace oh thank you
well i'll answer the latter question
first i refer
very reverently to
most indian food as various colors of
goop and i've visited with my
indian friend i've visited india before
and i never can remember the name so
i'll say like i like the green goop and
i like the
the orange goop i probably would get sag
paneer
always go for that i'd probably get i'm
kind of a basic american guy so i'd
probably get like a
chicken tikka masala sort of thing get
some of that delicious naan you know i
can
i can get into indian food i really like
that and as far as the non-theistic
religions
i do have obviously i don't agree with
them and i don't believe in them and i'm
not
a member of those faiths however i i do
think that
non-theistic religion can tell us
something about the world
and actually can point toward theistic
religion and specifically christianity
there is i visited varanasi which is
this sort of
ancient spiritual city it's a really
really amazing city
with such uh abundant relig not
non-theistic generally speaking
religious life though i did visit a few
kind of ruined
churches and things like that uh what
does that tell us
i think it was uh there was some famous
prelate
who said that if you if you ever leave
christianity you should become a pagan
and the reason for that is that uh
paganism and and
the ancient myths also will tell you
something about the natural world and
and
the way that these myths came into being
is because people were perceiving
something about the world and they have
a lot of
truth truth telling capacity
and the difference with christianity
seems to me is that christianity is
as louis would say a true myth it is
it has all the mythic qualities of the
non-theistic religions
uh but it also is incarnational and it
also really
happened and it also continues to happen
today so that's my view
it's a respectful view that i think that
i think points toward
what i would call true religion from lex
dear michael
first i would like to say that i'm a big
fan and appreciate everything you do
thank you i'm glad you said that first
second i've been thinking about how the
biden administration is holding over 300
percent more children in cages than
trump
and couldn't help wonder if a third of
these crimes against humanity
made trump hitler does this make biden
now these comparisons
between the two seem endless thank you
again
no it doesn't because i mean actually in
a way sure let's say that it does do
that
even worse than pointing out the
hypocrisy in the double standard
between trump and biden think about the
hypocrisy and the double standard
between
hitler and mao hitler very very very
bad guy did a lot of very very very bad
things
now very very bad guy did very very very
bad things
awful totalitarian leaders of their
country committed
horrific crimes you can wear a shirt
with mao's face on it you can't wear a
shirt with hitler's face on it
i don't think you should wear a shirt
with either face on it but in this
culture
we have defined one
evil ideology as sort of the soul
exclusive evil in politics
and other evil ideologies we find
fashionable you could wear a shirt with
stalin on it there are actual stalinists
around today
che guevara is the great example you
could you could totally wear a shirt
with shay guevaras now
you'd be cool you'd be on a college
campus so sure you'd say okay well trump
is hitler and biden's mao
but it doesn't matter if you're mao
because because mao does not receive the
program that he ought to in our culture
last question from dusty hey michael
with all this craziness going on in our
country today i find it extremely
difficult to see the good things on the
horizon
i know it's always darkest before dawn
but do you think we are fighting a
losing battle in this country
or do you think the future is still
bright thanks for being informative and
willing to fight well yeah it's always
darkest before dawn it's always
always darkest before it goes totally
black so
the question is which way are we going i
am neither an optimist
nor a pessimist i have hope which is a
fact
it's a theological virtue and it's a
fact and here's my hope
i know that the story ends well i know
that my redeemer lives i know
that good defeats evil in the end
also i know things are going to get very
very
very bad before that happens and will
that
intersect with our lifetime i don't know
i mean there's a world in which the
country gets
way better for the next i don't know 50
60 years and then at that point
you know it's not ain't my problem
anymore or there's a problem that gets
worse and worse and worse and
things don't get better for 100 years
200 years 300 years maybe they don't get
better
but i don't i don't place my joys and my
my longings and that sort of thing
i do what i can for the day and
i i place my my hopes in
eternal things to quote a friend of mine
from the bronx
who is this great guy down there in the
bronx he wears and i love jesus hat
baker super cool guy he says i do my
best buddy boy
and god does the rest easy enough for me
i'm michael nolis the michael knowles
show see on monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me
andrew clavin